des dizaines de milliers de mises en
chantier sont prévues cette année au
québec mais votre entrepreneur attire
les compétences requises pour effectuer
les travaux
selon la loi sur le bâtiment une licence
de la rbq devrait être gage de qualité
confiance dans son rapport la
vérificatrice générale affirme que la
rbq la régie du bâtiment du québec ne
prend pas les moyens appropriés pour
vérifier les compétences des
entrepreneurs à qui elle accorde des
licences
nous avons d'abord constaté que la
stratégie et les moyens mis en oeuvre
par la régie du bâtiment pour s'assurer
des compétences des entrepreneurs sont
insuffisants en fait aucune évaluation
des compétences en exécution de travaux
de construction n'est requise pour
certains entrepreneurs spécialisés dont
l'excavation et le terrassement ou les
portes et fenêtres par exemple et les
plaintes sont nombreuses
savin toit qui coule ça peut faire
beaucoup de dégâts surtout quand ça
coule pas beaucoup derrière les murs ça
peut prendre longtemps avant qu'on s'en
rendre compte et qu'on s'en rende compte
il ya de la moisissure il ya énormément
de travail qui a été fait la régie n'est
pas parfaite
la régie promet des actions la majorité
des entrepreneurs seront par exemple
soumis à de la formation continue dès
l'an prochain pour garder leur licence
jusqu'ici il n'était pas obligé de
mettre à jour leurs connaissances
on veut avoir confiance il ça doit être
ainsi tout à fait on ne pollue le mènera
pas celui qui défend les consommateurs
insiste il ne faut pas se fier
uniquement à la licence si vous
connaissez quelqu'un de confiance qui a
eu une bonne expérience avec un
entrepreneur ça ça vaut delà la régie du
bâtiment du québec joue un rôle
essentiel dans un secteur clé de
l'économie en 2019 l'industrie de la
construction à elles seules représentait
53 milliards de dollars de dépenses
d'investissement ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morey